so I was watching your web series on
Bailey Street and you are building a
house from ground up this this is
clearly your dream right like this this
project is this the dream project more
than anything else you've ever done is
this no this has been something kicking
and screaming my wife dragged me to I
lived in this house for 26 years the
house was on a show called living with
that yeah I've been there since 88 I
loved it I used to joke but I wasn't
entirely joking that I would be
composted out back yeah you know and
then she kept saying from early on when
we were dating in the 90s you go hey you
need more closet space I don't have any
Road whoa whoa honey okay okay I hear
you you've got to find another guy you
got to start dating guys this is not
gonna work
I'm never gonna move from this house
ever read my lips I'm never moving yeah
and so I said that and I meant it 93 94
95 finally by 2010 she had worn me down
we had had three very successful years
for that show living with that an acting
career was doing good and green product
endorsements so we had the money to do
it she said we've got the money now
please
would you consider if I could get you
more solar rooftop space you get more
exposure for your panels if I could get
you a bigger vegetable garden I can get
you more room for a rainwater tank on
the ground would you move then I said
okay if you can find point
abcdefg for this price for F yeah then
I'll move yeah and the [ __ ] did it and
I found the place then I had a bath your
quote now I know yeah it's gonna be good
when we're moved into this house and
happy about it I'll feel very good about
it all because you can only do so much
with a retrofit I'm starting with an 88
when I bought that home it was a 1936
energy inefficient house there was no
insulation the walls whatsoever I blew
it in no insulation of the Attic
but these big recycled denim you know
bats up there did all this stuff one
thing after another I made it as
efficient as you could let me tell you
what you can do with new construction we
can blow incredible insulation in the
walls it's modern foam insulation the
walls are 12 inches thick it's passive
solar design so wintertime the Sun is
hitting the glass summer time and a
little before a little after no Sun is
hitting the glass incredible Lutron
smart equipment for the lighting control
shades and lighting fixtures incredible
hi seer rating heating and air units
variable flow for different zones it's
amazing what you can do with modern
construction and we're doing it all
solar low water use faucets and fixtures
everything that you can do we're doing
it